dominica de pizzas dominica hornea
diariamente la misma cantidad de pizzas
ella gasta 8 pesos diarios usando el
horno y 150 en los ingredientes de cada
pizza un día el precio de los
ingredientes aumentó de 150 a 2 pesos
por pizza dominica hizo algunas cuentas
y encontró que debería hornear 8 pizzas
más al día para que el precio de la
venta de sus pizzas quedara igual
escribe una ecuación para encontrar el
número de pizzas que hornea a diario
antes de que aumentó el precio usa pp
para representar el número de pizzas ok
vamos a ir sacando los datos de este
problema así que vámonos con calma dice
dominica de pizzas dominica hornea
diariamente la misma cantidad de pizzas
ok ya que hay un dato importante hornea
diariamente en la misma cantidad
ok ella gasta 8 pesos diarios 8 pesos
diarios
usando el horno y 1 5150 en los
ingredientes de cada una de las pizzas
que hornea cada día un día aumento los
precios de 150 a 2 pesos por pizza
aumenta el precio de los ingredientes
por pizza y entonces dominica hizo
algunas cuentas y encontró que debería
hornear 8 pizzas más 8 pizzas más al día
para que el precio de venta de sus
pizzas quedara igual y aquí hay una de
las palabras claves de este problema
quedará igual quedará igual
escribe una ecuación para encontrar el
número de pizzas cornea va a diario
antes del momento del precio usa pp para
representar el número de pizzas muy bien
pues vamos vaciando la información que
me da este problema vamos a pensar
primero qué es lo que pasa con dominica
antes de que el precio aumente entonces
voy a poner aquí antes antes de que el
precio aumente y después nos vamos a
fijar en qué es lo que
pasa con dominica después de que el
precio mente antes de que impresión
mente que es lo que gasta dominica bueno
ella va a gastar ocho pesos diarios
usando el horno así que por día va a
gastar 8 pesos pulsando el horno y estos
son de cajón forzosamente diario va a
gastar 8 pesos horneando la misma
cantidad de pizzas que por cierto el
precio de los ingredientes de cada una
de las pizzas es de 150 así que se
hornea p&p pizzas porque justo es lo que
no sabemos qué pizzas hornear antes de
que aumente el precio y ojo eso es muy
importante antes de que aumente el
precio entonces por cada una de ellas va
a pagar unos 50 entonces a 8 pesos que
se gastan diario usando el horno le voy
a aumentar 150 150 por la cantidad de
pizzas que hornee durante todo el día y
para eso voy a denotar lo pon pp es la
cantidad de pizzas que va a ahora los
ingredientes de cada una de las pizzas
vale 150 y esto es lo que se gasta en
total por día y si a esto lo dividimos
entre
de pizzas a esto lo voy a dividir entre
la cantidad de pizzas que vende en ese
día que por cierto nosotros sabemos que
es la cantidad que hornea diariamente es
decir pero si esto lo dividimos entre p
aquí estoy representando lo que cuesta
cada una de las pizzas en total por día
estoy viendo cuánto se gasta en total
esta dominica y lo estoy dividiendo
entre la cantidad de pizzas por lo tanto
aquí estoy representando lo que cuesta
en total hacer cada una de las pizzas ok
y ahora si pensamos en qué es lo que va
a pasar después de que aumente el precio
bueno después de que aumente el precio
va a pasar algo importante la cantidad
primero quiero que te des cuenta que
ella va a seguir usando el horno y por
lo tanto va a gastar 8 pesos diarios
usando el horno eso no va a cambiar ok
hasta aquí vamos bien y después a esto
le vamos a agregar le vamos a agregar ok
y ahora cambie el precio de los
ingredientes por pizza de 150 a 2 pesos
por lo tanto en lugar de gastar unos 50
por la cantidad de pizzas
dos pesos por la cantidad de pizzas que
va a hornear después de que aumente el
precio y justo aquí está lo más
importante de todo este problema no es
la misma p date cuenta que aquí dice que
dominica hizo algunas cuentas y encontró
que debería hornear 8 pizzas más al día
para que el precio de venta de sus
pizzas quedará igual 8 pizzas más por lo
tanto ahora no va a estar haciendo pp
pizzas va a estar trabajando va a estar
horneando p más 8 pizzas es decir que si
yo quiero ver cuánto se gasta en total
dominica bueno pues tengo los 8 pesos
del horno más 2 pesos por cada una de
las pizzas pero actualmente acp más 8
pizzas p más 8 pizzas o espera no más 18
más 8 pizzas porque aumenta la cantidad
de pizzas que va a ser dominica ok y si
a esto lo divido entre la cantidad de
pizzas que hace actualmente es decir
después de que aumentó el precio que por
cierto nosotros ya sabemos que este más
8 ya esto lo divido entre p más 8
y eso representando lo que cuesta en
total hacer una de las pizzas después de
que aumenta el precio es decir ahora que
los ingredientes por pizza valen dos
pesos y bueno nosotros sabemos que hace
ocho pizzas más eso es importante ahora
hasta aquí creo que vamos todo viene sin
embargo quiero hacer notar que viene
otras partes más importantes de todo
este problema si nosotros analizamos
esta oración con mucho cuidado entonces
vamos a poder encontrar justo en la
ecuación que estamos buscando y vamos a
poder resolver para penn si te das
cuenta dice que dominica hizo algunas
cuentas y encontró que debería hornear 8
pizzas más al día aquí ya lo pusimos
para que el precio de venta de sus
pizzas quedara igual y eso es muy
importante si queremos que el precio de
venta de sus pizzas quede igual entonces
lo que cuesta hacer cada una de sus
pizzas antes de que aumente el precio
debe de ser exactamente igual debe de
ser exactamente igual a lo que cuesta
hacer cada una de sus pizzas después de
que aumente el precio del
ingredientes esta parte que dice que el
precio de venta de sus pizzas quedará
igual lo que significa es que estas dos
expresiones matemáticas deben de ser
iguales y si son iguales ya tenemos una
ecuación que podemos resolver para pep
si te das cuenta solamente tengo una
incógnita que es p
así que qué te parece si nos ponemos las
pilas y vamos a resolver y vamos a
resolver esta ecuación que tengo tiene y
bueno para esto si te das cuenta aquí
tengo dos expresiones que representan
fracciones y a mí no me gusta trabajar
con fracciones así que para eso voy a
multiplicar todas toda esta ecuación por
los dos denominadores es decir voy a
multiplicar y déjenme mover un poco para
cada pantalla para cada pantalla
voy a multiplicar esta parte por pe ok
para eliminar esta p pero también voy a
multiplicar por p más 88 para que de
este lado cuando yo multiplique por pe y
después por p más 8 x p más 8 voy a
eliminar así este otro denominador
entonces voy a multiplicar de ambos
lados por p que multiplica a 8 y esto
que podamos eliminar los denominadores
que nos estorban aquí cuando nosotros
tenemos fracciones recuerda que a mí no
me gusta trabajar mucho con fracciones
prefiero tener una ecuación que se vea
un poco más amigable así que vamos a
eliminar esta p con esta p y aquí me
quedarían bueno pues me va a quedar p
más ocho temas 8 que multiplican déjame
ponerlo con este color que multiplica a
8 + 1.50 por p esto del lado izquierdo
de la ecuación mientras que el lado
derecho me va a quedar que esté más 8
con este tema 8 se van y solamente me
queda p que multiplican y déjame cambiar
de color vamos a ponerlo con este color
de aquí que multiplica a 8 + 2 que a su
vez multiplica apenas 810 más vamos a
hacerlo de una vez
si yo multiplico este de aquí este 2 por
p más 8 me va a quedar 2 que multiplica
p y 2 que multiplica 8 es decir 8 más
+ + 16 ok de lujo así que ya tengo esta
expresión de aquí y si te das cuenta lo
único que tengo es una multiplicación
algebraica así que bueno pues vamos a
hacerla voy a multiplicar esta p por
este y esta p por este y me va a quedar
pp por 8 es 8 pm 8 pm más p por 150 p
bueno estos 150 p cuadrada ok y después
hay que multiplicar este por este y este
por éste y me va a quedar 8 por 8 64 ok
y 8 por unos 50 es lo mismo que tres por
4 lo cual es 12 + 12 pm ok esto tiene
que ser exactamente igual esto tiene que
ser igual y bueno voy a multiplicar
ahora de este otro lado de la ecuación y
me va a quedar 8 pm 8 p más ap por 2 p
es 16 p cuadrada ok
16 p 16 p de lujo lo único que hice fue
multiplicar por los dos denominadores
para que se fueran y así tener
multiplicaciones algebraicas muy fáciles
de hacer aún así te das cuenta que abajo
tenemos una ecuación cuadrática así que
vamos a resolverla para esto voy a bajar
la pantalla bajemos bajemos bajemos la
pantalla para poder trabajar mejor lo
que falta del problema y guau aquí tengo
un 8 pm y 18 pm 8 p de un lado izquierdo
y 8 p del lado derecho se pueden ir es
decir si yo restó 8 p de ambos lados de
la ecuación este ciudad y este también
se va entonces me va a quedar que tengo
150 p cuadrada más 64 más 12 p esto es
igual a 16 p cuadrada más 16 p sin
embargo aquí tengo una ecuación
cuadrática así que qué te parece si
mejor ponemos todos los términos de un
lado de la ecuación para poderla
resolver de una manera mucho más
sencilla y entonces me va a quedar a
déjame poner primero la parte izquierda
tengo
1.50 por p cuadrada
y después voy a poner este más 12 pm ok
más 64 esto tiene que ser igual y ahora
voy a poner la parte izquierda que me
queda 16 p cuadrada no no no no aquí
debe de haber algo raro 16 p cuadradas
muchísimo a ver qué dice p x 8 8 pm p x
2 p claro claro claro aquí está el error
aquí no es 16 p cuadrada aquí es 2p
cuadrada te das cuenta lo que hice fue
multiplicar por ocho quién sabe porque
aquí es 2 p cuadrada perdón fue un error
que nos iba a tener muchos problemas
después es decir que del lado derecho
tengo 2p cuadrado más 16 p ok de lujo yo
creo que me confundí con este 16 p pero
bueno fue un error que podemos a
corregir de una manera muy rápida
entonces ahora lo que voy a hacer es
restar de este lado 2p cuadrada para que
éstos se vayan y 16 p cuadrada para que
esto se vaya también y nos quede igual a
20 pero lo que voy a hacer del lado
izquierdo
hacer exactamente igual del lado derecho
es decir que aquí me va a quedar menos 2
p cuadrada y aquí menos 16 p ok y ahora
sí si nosotros sumamos estas dos
expresiones que tengo aquí este de aquí
y estar acá entonces me va a quedar de
este lado este y este se va este y este
se va y del lado izquierdo me queda 150
p cuadrada menos 2p cuadrado bueno si
tengo unos 50 pesos menos 2 pesos me
queda menos menos 0.5 p cuadrada ok aquí
tengo 12 pm 16 pm esto es lo mismo que
menos 4 p
ok y aquí bajo es 64 + 64 y esto es
igual a 0 y es que es importantísimo
tenerlo igual a 0 porque aquí ya tengo
una ecuación cuadrática la cual puede
resolver de muchas maneras puede
utilizar fórmula general puedo
factorizar puedo completar el binomio al
cuadrado perfecto vamos a resolverla y
bueno para esto déjenme bajar un poco la
pantalla para
de resolver este problema a mí lo que me
gusta mucho es factorizar así que para
esto no puede factorizar desde aquí lo
que se me ocurre es multiplicar toda la
ecuación por menos 2 para quitar este
0.5 que tengo aquí entonces
multiplicamos todo todo por menos 2
menos 2 de tal manera que aquí me va a
quedar solamente p cuadrada menos x
menos me da más 2 por 0.5 bueno eso es
uno aquí me va a quedar p cuadrada y
después tengo menos 2 x menos 4 esto es
8 pm 8 pm y después tengo menos 2 por 64
esto es menos 128 menos 128 esto tiene
que ser igual a 0 x menos 2 lo cual es 0
de lujo y esta expresión díaz es mucho
más amigable para factorizar y justo eso
es lo que voy a hacer ahorita voy a
buscar dos números que su producto sea
menos 128 su producto producto que por
cierto date cuenta que uno debe de ser
positivo y el otro negativo y además que
cuando yo me tomé
más de ambos la suma de 8 la suma estoy
buscando este par de números y bueno se
me ocurre a ver 128 y 1 no no no estos
no me sirven 128 y si lo divido entre 2
y 64 12 64 no tampoco me sirven si tengo
ha sido 128 entre a entre 8 cuánto me
dan 128 entre 8 me cabe una vez uno por
ocho es 8 y aquí le voy a restar 8 y
después aquí bajo un 4 aquí hay 18 y me
queda 6 por 8 48 6 16 16 y 8 o perfecto
16 y 8 si me funcionan fíjate bien 128
lo puedo ver como 16 positivo y 8
negativo
ok 16 por menos 8 mil 128 negativo y
después si yo a lo sumo me queda 16 más
menos 8 bueno esos 16 menos 8 en lo cual
es porque del ojo si me funciona es
decir estoy diciendo que está express
cuadrática que tengo aquí es exactamente
lo mismo que tomarme p 16 p 16 que a su
vez es multiplicar ap - 8 y esto a su
vez es igual a cero ok y lo estoy factor
izando así porque cuando yo factor y es
una expresión cuadrática que es igual a
cero esto ya es mucho más fácil de
trabajar lo estoy diciendo que open más
16 16 esto es igual a cero o en su dado
caso o en su dado caso a este es de
color amarillo déjame ponerlo p - 8 es
igual a cero ok de la primera yo puedo
despejar de aquí apem y decir que pepe
es igual o espera déjame cambiar de
color p es igual a menos 16 ok o en su
dado caso p p es igual a 8 si de aquí
despejó ap lo único que hice fue igual a
estas 2 a 0 porque si tengo dos números
multiplicándose igual a cero o el
primero es 0 o el segundo es cero
ok y entonces ya tengo dos posibles
resultados o que psa igual a 16
o en su dado caso que pese a igual a 8
estos dos resultados hacen que se cumpla
esta ecuación cuadrática con la que
nosotros estábamos trabajando esta
ecuación cuadrática aquí o esta ecuación
cuadrática de aquí y en este momento
puedes decir hoy acabamos el problema de
igualdad menos 16 o p igual a 8 y ya me
voy sin embargo ten cuidado vamos a
revisar el problema para ver bien qué
dice así que aprende estos dos valores y
vamos para arriba de igual a menos 16
pehual a 8 subiendo subiendo o espera
esto está haciendo más grande no no no
no yo quiero un poco más pequeño ok y
ahora si subimos entonces tengo dos
posibles resultados o que pm sea igual a
menos 16 o en su dado caso que sea igual
a 81 cuál de los dos nos quedamos bueno
ambos solucionen la ecuación cuadrática
sin embargo p igual a menos 16 no tiene
sentido en el contexto del problema no
podemos pensar que dominica hace menos
16 pizzas al día porque entonces pues
estaría en la bancarrota estaría
vendiendo una cantidad negativa y eso no
tiene sentido
o podemos eliminar esta solución que
tengo aquí voy a eliminar esta solución
que tengo aquí y me voy a quedar
solamente con p igual ahora porque es
una cantidad positiva y además la
podemos utilizar en este contexto de
pizzas y p representaba el número de
pizzas que ordenaba a diario antes de
que aumentará el precio entonces antes
de que aumentaba el precio dominica
horneaba 8 pizzas después de que aumenta
el precio dominica va a hornear 8 pizzas
más es decir va a hornear 8 816 pizzas
en total esto después de que aumente el
precio de los ingredientes por pizza y
ya está resuelto el problema de las
pizzas de dominica y tanta pizzeria me
dio hambre así que nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo